hi there Steve Kaufman we're getting
closer to the start of the 90 day
challenge just a few days away so I just
thought I'd first of all tell you the
language that I'm going to go for i'm
going to do polish i had thought of
doing korean but i have done korean
before and i'm continuing to do korean
as a minor but my major emphasis is
going to be on polish I've never spoken
polish I have dabbled a bit in Polish at
link I have an advantage in Polish
because a lot of the vocabulary is
similar to a Ukrainian and check and
it's a language that I would like to get
to where I can understand and speak and
so that's where my emphasis is you want
to be a couple of words on what you can
expect to achieve you know everything
depends on how close the languages to a
language you already know so and i also
i like to think in terms with three
stages in language learning the first
stage you start becoming familiar with
the language you can tell when listening
where one word ends and the next word
begins you start to be able to say a few
things that's kind of getting somewhat
used to the language so that it isn't
strange anymore that's a good three
months depending how many hours you put
in so if you're a beginner that's really
I think what you can expect to achieve
in three months but it depends how close
the language is if if you're going from
spanish to portuguese you can achieve
more i'm going from say ukrainian and
check to polish so i will achieve more
my Korean it just takes me a lot longer
because that second stage where you the
language is no longer strange your basic
sense of how it works but you just don't
have enough words and especially when
you're in a language which is written in
a different writing system and there are
very few common words it just takes an
awful lot longer and it's not the
structure of the language it's the words
because even if if Japanese or Korean is
structured very differently from English
if the words were all familiar I could
make it out but it's the lack of words
and so again be realistic if you're
doing a language that has a lot of
common vocabulary with a language that
you know you're going to do better but
at any rate I will be updating your
regular
with videos talking about about my
specific goals what I'm doing and
hopefully that will be of use to you and
I very much encourage you in order to go
after a period of concentrated effort
this 90-day challenge and one more thing
i invite you to send in your questions
one witty video a week I'm going to be
answering questions from our you know
other participants and I should point
out as I think I did in the previous
video that members of our link team mark
Sam and Kieran and Miguel are also going
to be doing the 90 day challenge so best
of luck to you in your 90 day challenge
and look forward to hearing from you bye
for now